here you go Snopes did Blues Clues Pride
Parade feature a beaver with top scars
true that's from Snopes now why are they
showing your children Pride parades with
people with top scars the issue is I may
not be
like when they come out and they say
something like oh not that many kids are
getting it you're exaggerating it's like
I never came out and said every kid was
getting it this is the weird thing when
Joe when Matt Walsh was on Joe Rogan and
Rogan asked Matt Walsh how many kids are
doing this Matt Walsh what did he say
millions or something like that
uh he said some ridiculous number and
then everyone called him out because
it's thousands it's a it's in terms of
cross-sex hormones I think it's around
50 000 in terms of puberty blockers it's
like 17 000 and in terms of uh
mastectomies for for uh adolescent girls
it's in the thousands like between one
and two thousand and I was like well I
don't I can't speak for anybody else but
I never came out and said oh heavens me
so many there's too many kids getting
this it must be in the millions I was
like one kid getting this is not good
and you know why because in Scandinavia
they piloted this and then said whoa
this isn't working and abandoned it and
in the UK they piloted this and then
said whoa this is not working and
abandon it and not only were the
children that they were trying to treat
still suicidal or or depressed the
surgeries and the and the medical
intervention actually increased or or
made these things worse or did nothing
at all so all it does is increase risk
my point is why are we encouraging
children to do it it's if if you're
gonna come mom be like ah it's only 50
000 on these hormones then I'll be like
okay if you don't think that's too many
what would be too many if the left says
who cares not that many kids are getting
it my response is what is the number by
then by by which you would then say I am
allowed to be concerned that children
are undergoing treatments that we've
already seen in for other countries fail
what what's the number is it not 50 is
it 75 is it 100 is it 200 okay here's
the point if Blues Clues keeps pushing
this stuff give it five ten years we
will be at a hundred thousand how about
we just call it out right now and say
let's not get to that number well let's
be honest we're not going near far
enough to stop it right now either I'm
glad we're finally waking up and finally
calling it out and we're what do you
mean we're passing laws we're we're
we're Banning it across the country
passing laws we have the major the
biggest children's organization in the
United States of America Disney
sexually grooming children with this
stuff over and over and over again and I
realize I don't and I applaud Florida
for what they're doing going after tax
exams at us we're a nation with many
children in it if you have a corporation
in your nation that has dedicated part
of its mission to attacking the children
of your nation that Corporation should
immediately be shut down immediately
should sit in the National Guard should
send in the rain but well if we're
interested in real solutions yeah okay
so we're Banning it in what a few states
where we're at 20 States now okay so
that well by my map in a couple years
that leaves us 30 States who are still
doing it and will slowly incrementally
do this and what's going to happen is
we're eventually going to have a bunch
of kind of red states where you can't do
most of this stuff but you can do a
little and then these blue Sodom and
Gomorrah freaking hell holes where we're
carving where Dr Frankenstein is just
operating on these kids every other day
and where did that where do we end up we
ended up so evil we ended up still bad
it's exactly right we're not nipping it
in the butt in the right way but we're
finally engaging but we're still taking
half measures all we do is half pressure
after half measure I disagree because I
don't think there's much Beyond making
it illegal
if if we're headed towards a point where
and I've talked about this we had the
story of uh Jeff younger I believe his
name was he was on this show yeah yeah
Jeff he has a kid who his wife took to
California which is a sanctuary I
remember and I'm like look man the
number one thing we don't want we don't
want Civil War we don't want divorce we
don't want violence because then China
wins because then our foreign
adversaries just take over and the U.S
just it'll be it'll be conflict nobody
wants to experience but if they are
unwilling if if I'll put it this way
the right tends to be
as a collective whatever you would call
the right in the culture War I would say
actually relatively of limited morals
meaning the Christian conservatives are
particularly moralistic and have a set
of morals but then you have a lot of
Libertarians you have a lot of
traditional liberals and the morals
within this group are disparate they
differ the one thing they hold is like
truth what is true what is not true so
you can have an individual like Jimmy
Dore who disagrees on economic policy
for opinion reasons based on what we
don't know to be absolute but he'll tell
you oh yeah these things did happen I
agree with you you're right that news
story did happen I read that that's true
and so the issue I see is with
everything the left is doing pertaining
to the expansion of abortion to the
point of birth and the um what do they
call gender affirming sanctuaries the
only end result of all of this in my
opinion is going to be conflict because
of what we I'll take a look at history
we take a look at the history of the
Civil War and the moral issues
surrounding slavery
and what was it there were a lot of
people in northern states
and despite the fact that Northerners
were extremely racist and they overall
did not care about slavery there were
large factions of abolitionists who only
cared about slavery and were willing to
travel to other states and territories
to outright murder people to end slavery
and there's interesting questions about
do we believe those people were morally
Justified so let's stop and put it this
way
do people
hold John Brown in high esteem
the answer is yes they do despite the
fact that he was a murderous terrorist
that's by the fact that he and his sons
would walk up to slave owners and just
murder them and for me I'm kind of like
I think that's a bad thing and we don't
want anything like that happening now
because you have to understand what that
means it means either antifa will
determine that our systems our
institutions are worthy of being burnt
to the ground which they they do and the
violence will escalate or then you get
conservatives who act like John Brown
which only makes the conflict worse and
then you end up in Mass War the question
of who wins I'm not entirely sure
I will just say I don't know with
watching all of this at what point
people come back together and this
country heals and I'm not convinced it's
possible because you look at what
happened in 2020 with the uh the war the
the election war game where apparently
John podesta
we're all playing this game said that if
Donald Trump were to have won in 2020
the West Coast uh States should secede
from the union like where does all of
this lead to the secession uh and the
breakup of the United States talk James
Lindsay was talking to Vivek ramaswamy
on vivek's YouTube channel a few days
ago and they were saying it's like in
war in in combat if you want to destroy
your enemy you do not surround them
because if you surround them they'll
fight to the death if you want to
destroy your enemy you surround them on
three sides and you give them one Escape
Route and then when they flee when they
see that route then they take it and
they flee that's when you jump on them
and Destroy them when they're routing so
a lot in Ukraine right now too by the
way it's the same in the culture War
what's happening is they're giving
people an Escape Route in the guise of
national divorce and that's the mistake
do not take that path that's that's the
destruction of everything is if we if we
think that the solution States yeah if
we if we assume the path is this is the
dissolution maybe no hold on hold on
that's one Escape Route that we've been
given what United States these United
States no no no no no no no what what
United States the one we want to exist
or the one that actually exists like
we've been talking about things like Tim
keeps bringing up about European nations
far ahead of us who have stopped these
horrible procedures for children but
look let's keep going back let's keep
going back to covet these European
nations that I personally and I know
many of us have mocked ah like a
socialist idiot Europeans were far ahead
of us here we here in the United States
of America especially on the right we
have a very nostalgic view of the
country that we still think exists now
there are still gigantic pockets of this
country that do exist in that way but
the government in its current form and I
will include our education system
Entertainment System our Sport Systems
this country is one of the most broken
and corrupt countries in the entire
planet and there's not it's not even a
question about it one of the most broken
and corrupt countries in the entire
planet what United States are we talking
about because it's not the United States
of Grandpa and World War or two are on
the beaches of Normandy and it's not the
United States of America from the year
2000. it's the United States of America
where our pride Flags fly from embassies
across we sexually mutilate children in
this nation over and over again we have
politician after politician after
politician in this country that took
part in all that covid Madness dumping
all over everybody keeping their seats
of power after they did so they all got
richer while we have inflation raging
and Mom and Pops can't buy eggs at the
grocery store the United States GOP and
Senate or the GOP and Democrats in the
Senate came together and passed a 1.7
trillion dollar bill that was just a big
handout to all of their friends it
didn't even it didn't even pretend like
it did anything for the people we have a
broke we don't have a United States of
America that's a lie we all have a
United States that's a nostalgic lie and
that's it no that's not it but but Let's
do let's do acknowledge reality
huge pop pockets of the country that can
be saved but let's let's let let's stop
talking about we the people they know we
the people everyone's seen that pool I'm
sure you guys have talked about it on
the show what was it 68 of Democrats
thought you should be arrested or locked
in your home if you didn't take a Kobe
vaccine don't tell me I'm sharing a
country with that person that person's
my enemy that's it oh worse we're a late
stage Republic is what we are we're late
stage Republicans and the next stage is
is what Empire uh no I I hope not I I
believe that it's empire because history
probably says that it's empire and
that's just somewhere across the Rubicon
yeah that's freaking horrible but yeah I
I believe the era and this really sucks
because I love teeny tiny government I
believe the era of limited government is
laughably past us that we will never get
back to that again because the people
only people who crew crave limited
government are people who've experienced
real tyranny like the founders have but
since we haven't really really
experienced the teeth of that yet now
it's just big government right and big
government yet left so it's either
Empire or whether it's some official
divorce or secession or whatever kind of
crazy word you want to put on it we are
living in two Americas and you better
get to the part where they don't want to
cut your son's penis off and you better
get there now because the other part
ain't backing off they're not
apologizing they're not moderating
they're not backing away in fact they're
taking our people and they're throwing
them in prison which is why don't buy in
Hazard Bush
no more he said there was a coup in the
United States in 1963 when the
government killed Kennedy and uh that
was it just shook me I I think he's
right and I don't know
what to do about it I the Federal Bureau
of Investigation just got busted
infiltrating the Catholic church I I
brought this I brought up this point
recently and I want people to really
take in what this means when the
government when the United States
government when they focus on one when
they Mission focus on one enemy they
destroy that enemy they've done it in
the past with the Soviet Union Cold War
Focus everything CIA FBI government
policy your Economic Policy your
military everything focused destroy this
Soviet Union took them down then we
focused on Islamic Jihad don't get
started Luke we got focused on Islamic
Jihad the CIA how many of those people
how many of those people did we kill
across the planet and I'm not not
bad-mouthing killing terrorists how many
did we kill across the planet millions
and people need to understand now that
same Mission Focus across NSA CIA FBI
United States government state
department they are mission focused on
the American right within our borders we
will have people say things like they're
destroying our military no they're
purging the dissident right out of the
military because the rebuilt and the
police because they're building one and
they're building one for a different
purpose I don't believe in this idea
that we're just one election away from
home there's no we're not I certainly
don't think so either and I've been
talking about this it's been a couple
years actually there was a video where a
guy is attacked by antifa and is fleeing
and the police show up apologize to
antifa and arrest him yep yep and I saw
the same thing in Dallas Texas red state
of Dallas Texas some child drag show and
of course antifa shows up to beat up
anyone who protests it and the Dallas
Police Department not not the antifa
guys in Mass with weapons they mob the
one dude who was trying to walk down the
sidewalk by himself and he's yelling at
him he said why are you harassing me
there's some angry violent right there I
saw this in uh in Canada it was um
trucker protest press for Truth uh
Dan Dix Dan Dix recorded the videotape
he was uh filming and he got surrounded
by far left extremists so the police
grabbed him and and said if you don't
leave we'll arrest you and he said what
they attacked me we don't care get out
or we'll arrest you and so this is the
thing I got to tell you part of it feels
really good I I imagine Luke is probably
you know every so often smiling a little
bit that conservatives who supported all
of the the expansion of police powers
and of the of DHS and things like that
in the Patriot Act are now the ones who
are being targeted by it because it's
probably a bit of shot and foot the only
problem is we're all caught in the same
same Maelstrom yep definitely not
smiling since uh again this is affecting
everyone and people have to understand
this is also going to affect the left as
well the revolution eats its own and
first when we exactly and when we look
at historically what happens during
these big political shifts uh especially
in China especially during the cultural
revolution especially in in the Soviet
Union you see a lot of the Top members
you see a lot of the people who helped
this new party get into Power be purged
right away sacrificed murdered and
genocided in so many different ways and
this is why this is such a dangerous
turn turning point in America and after
9 11 I was warning people hey you know
the Patriot Act destroying the
Constitution spying on American citizens
torturing renditioning people drone
bombing and killing people that are
American citizens maybe is not a good
idea and I think this is why the right
doesn't have as much leverage doesn't
have have as much respect and why we
have such a big cultural pushback
because during the bush years they have
essentially destroyed this country
destroyed the US Constitution indebted
this country printed money out of thin
air and has led us to this horrible
situation where now the people on the
left are like well if they get in power
they're going to create more war they're
going to destroy our constitution so we
got to do it first and now the Democrats
are doing it and now the Republicans are
aware the Democrats used to be and the
seats are changing but in reality we're
just being propelled left and right
towards this totalitarian status hell
hole and more people are saying we just
got to vote for the lesser of two evils
and this is what led us here and we've
been warning about it we've been warning
about it for such a long time well and
everyone said you're crazy you're kooky
you're a conspiracy nope here we are
today and there's and and I don't know
how we're going to go back shout out to
Dr Ron Paul we had him on last night it
was an honor and a privilege and Luke
shared with me a meme from the show so
Luke's sitting over here and he says he
asks of Dr Paul are they malicious or
are they ignorant are they stupid or are
they evil and what did Dr Paul say Ron
Paul Just Smiles like yes
I was like which one he's like no yes
yeah great great response and then he
talked about how they are ignorant and
they are that's absolutely evil in many
instances and and this is what happens
when you have this two kind of duopoly
system that has hijacked our government
and again when it comes to you know even
even the administration before this the
national debt the the lockdowns the the
emergencies that doesn't help anyone as
well printing money out of dinner giving
everyone two thousand dollar checks
which amounted to nothing by the way
compared to all the corporate banking
bailouts which as you said were huge
sums of money that they just gave their
friends Republicans and Democrats
Republicans and Democrats Republicans
were all for lockdowns Republicans were
all for passing these trillion dollar
bills just like the Democrats they were
attacking Sweden they were attacking
Sweden and their own fellow Republican
politicians that were like you know
maybe 15 days to slow the spread is a
really bad idea when we allow Walmart to
be open but we shut down the small mama
pop stores maybe that's a bad idea and
then the president of the United States
at the time attacked that politician
very vicious and you know let's let's
call it out here let's be let's be
honest with ourselves uh because I think
this is a major issue of concern and and
major issues that are holding the right
back from actually achieving something
good and again this is why I don't have
a lot of faith in the right I have a lot
of faith in the American people I don't
vote that don't support the system that
are sick and tired of this bullcrap and
are are taking matters into their own
health by being personally responsible I
I think we're on a track to Victory to
be completely honest I I think we win at
the end of all of this I think the the
future will be 50 to 100 years the
country will be much more patriotic it
will be much more like that as you put
it World War II greatest Generation you
know go America I'll give you a few
reasons why if we follow the straws
house uh how generational Theory we are
in the fourth turning which means just
by the nature of how Generations operate
we are in the worst of it and the worst
of it will create strong men who create
Good Times who will in turn then later
on create weak men but that means the
next the next phase is the first we're
in the fourth turning a period of tumult
will happen and then there will be a
period where we start picking up and
climbing up
so I think we're seeing the worst of it
now over the next couple of years it's
predicted to get very bad maybe it's
world war three maybe it's Civil War
maybe it's hot War maybe it's not and
then we'll have a period where the
strong men start to rebuild as we have
seen throughout history in this country
and many others the other issue that I
think is worth pointing out is that
conservatives have kids they may not
have enough kids but all that matters is
they have twice as many as liberals
Liberals are more likely to abort their
kids more likely to sterilize themselves
and their kids and conservatives right
now have actually been pushing the
talking point of having as many kids as
possible which means we may actually see
a boost due to the culture among what I
would just refer to as the freedom
faction because it's not just
conservatives it's also disaffected
liberals and Libertarians people are
saying have more kids have at least two
have three because Liberals are having
one on average and and if that give that
20 years you know what that means if
every conservative family has four
children right now in 20 years you will
have four times the youth voter base now
of course the left tries to indoct
indoctrinate your kids but what what
else are we seeing in the cultural
Zeitgeist among the right is homeschool
your kids bring your kids into into
homeschooling pods and get away from
these schools the other big factor that
I think shows run a path to Victory is
the fleeing of these Urban centers to
places like Florida and Texas people who
actually pay attention are moving away
from these nightmarish hellholes and the
best part
I suppose the worst part for people to
live in the cities we just saw in
Portland kawava a coffee shop announced
finally they were shutting their doors
down because the violence and extremism
had grown too much for them to handle
and they couldn't take care of their
employees industry is collapsing and
they will soon have no access to
resources the one benefit the United
States had over say the Soviet Union is
that when the revolution happened they
topped down just started killing people
and implemented their weirdo communist
garbage who destroyed everything but we
have the Second Amendment and we're a
very very large country with smaller
subcultures within this country which
means when California La and SF for
instance get woke they go broke it will
be extremely difficult for the the law
enforcement of California to go to Texas
to force their way of life what does
that mean as you mentioned earlier Jesse
There are pockets of this country that
are still going strong and can be saved
it doesn't matter those those Pockets
aren't going to go anywhere you're not
going to be able to go in there and take
them down in fact tax is turning more
red Florida became a reliable red state
which means when California collapses
under the weight of its Democrat policy
garbage we're now seeing I I covered the
story it's gonna I did a segment on this
earlier but I'm putting it up on Friday
homeless camps popping up in Beverly
Hills you know what that means it means
all of these Hollywood celebrities who
invested their money in property are not
going to have a penny to give Grandma
because they're going to be underwater
hey look I got a 5 million movie
contract so I bought a 10 million dollar
house now I got I got an 8 million
dollar loan on that house but it's only
worth five million dollars I can't sell
it what can I do with it nobody wants to
come here there's homeless people in
crime everywhere guess what in places
like Texas and Florida things are
getting better in West Virginia things
are getting better but in the big cities
things are getting worse as long as all
of this continues the insulated and
somewhat isolated conservative Pockets
that are thriving will Thrive the
institutions of the left will eat
themselves and Destroy themselves the
beer companies will collapse for trying
to sell beer to children that don't want
to drink it or I should say to young
college kids destroying their Market
there's a reason why we say get what go
broke it's a tendency not a law over a
long enough period of time we have seen
more than enough examples of companies
embracing weakness and then losing money
because of it now of course they have
institutional capture they've got
weapons in the federal government but I
don't think in the long run that matters
because the weight is pressing on them
not us we are the people who are living
outside of the Cities who are leaving
these cities and getting away from it
and then thriving places like Florida
where Rhonda said history locked down
but he reopened up and then people
flooded to Florida where there's
beautiful beaches there's great weather
and people are having a party then
there's Texas Texas is turning redder as
well because people are coming here
because they want freedom which means
all of the attempts of the left to take
over has created an inverse pressure
system which is sending people out of
their states which costs them power
which reduces their revenue reduces
their income reduces their influence
and then they abort and sterilize their
kids so certainly we want to stop all
these bad things but I think the long
run is if we set back and just said stay
the course and keep doing everything
you're doing I think in a hundred years
it's over we completely won but if we
persist in the culture war and make sure
we're homeschooling our kids make sure
we aren't buying Anheuser-Busch products
20 to 30 years 20 to 30 years of
conservatives having four kids each and
you've got a voting block that has been
raised on winning a culture war and
that's all that matters four times the
new voters entering the system and it's
not even 20 it's 18 years in 18 years
from this day
conservatives can have four more votes
per family that's one for you one for
your significant other and four kids
granted you're not gonna have four kids
all at once so maybe within the span of
23 years you might have four kids who
are a voting age but liberals aren't
going to have any of that I would say
maybe and that's a very optimistic uh
look and perspective to have there which
which again is important to kind of
explore here but when we have open
immigration when we have populations
being replaced in California in New York
with another voting base that
particularly votes left uh with them
also making very significant moves
against the Second Amendment with them
crashing the petrol dollar with a a
native population crash of the western
world I think we're dealing with
something very severe that could also
happen in the exact inverse as you
described here as we're dealing with an
anti-human agenda that encourages the
destruction of the fan of the family
unit stops reproduction and pushes a
larger depopulation agenda that of
course is a total totalitarian control
grid so on on those aspects it could
swing either way but that open
immigration problem is something also
that I think we should be looking at I I
think I I think the southern border is a
crisis I think it is an issue and I
think there's a reason why Democrats
don't want to shut that to to shut the
border down to actually control it given
given 10 years California brings in more
and more people
and a lot of people on the right say
it's because they're they're voting
illegally they're not it doesn't they
don't need to vote the population of
illegal immigrants gives them more
electoral votes period and electoral
votes are the real votes that matter
California knows this New York knows
this Joe Biden knows this that's why
they bring in people bring them to these
states it changes the Electoral makeup
not
by having them vote by increasing the
amount of districts in the state so I
think in the in 2010 California had one
extra Congressional vote based on
non-citizens
so they're this they're not voting but
they're getting a vote I don't think
what do you think matters anymore thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time